have you taken a cognitive no i haven't
taken the test why the hell would i take
a test
come on man
he had a little pep in his step back
then well we hope that during biden's
first physical as president that that
cognitive test actually would happen and
even sanjay gupta seemed surprised it
didn't
i read pretty carefully through the
doctor's report and there was in they
mentioned neurological exam but that was
more in terms of testing motor strength
and sensation and things like that as
far as we know for president biden we
didn't see any kind of tests like that
performed
joining me now is texas congressman
ronnie jackson he also served as white
house physician under presidents obama
and trump all right congressman so the
current white house physician
says biden is fit to successfully
execute the duties of the presidency as
long as ron klain makes all the
decisions i'm joking um so how would we
know that without a cognitive test is
that important in your estimation
well it's absolutely important laura
especially in this particular situation
the man 79 years old 50 of the united
states population does not believe that
he's mentally fit cognitively fit to
lead this country as our
commander-in-chief and our head of state
and so
dr o'connor spent six pages talking
about useless stuff that no one cares
about and did not address the elephant
in the room which is is this man
cognitively fit to be our president
whenever president trump had his
physical done i did a cognitive test on
him president trump was the first
president to ever have one done and that
was because the far left and the liberal
media demanded they were relentless in
their pursuit of me in getting his
physical done and including the
cognitive test as part of that we did
that and i did it because i was 100 sure
the president there was a one single
thing wrong with president trump and he
he said let's do it ronnie i got nothing
to hide but they are just as sure right
now that biden would not do well in this
test and that's why they ran away from
this and they will not do it because
they know he'll fail miserably you know
he will validate what the what the
public thinks about him right now that
he's not fit to be our
commander-in-chief now they went they
went on and on about trump's cognitive
tests it was the most ridiculous thing
anyone who spent any time with president
trump there's no issue with his
cognitive abilities that's for sure
now here's a list of all the things that
the white house physician
says he checked okay optometry
odorolinology i can't say that ent
dentistry his dentistry orthopedics
physical neurology cardiology radiology
dermatology
anesthesiology and gastroenterology
congressman that sounds like a bad
scrabble contest but
dentistry what why do we care about
whether yeah you know he needs a root
canal or not this this makes
sense literally
he was literally just trying to fill the
report just trying to fill six pages of
the report and they did it as a written
release he should have got up there dr
o'connor who i don't who i know
personally he used to work for me i
don't really have a lot of respect for
the man to be honest with you i don't
think he's a man of integrity anyways
but he should have got up there and he
should have stood before the press you
know when i whenever i whenever whenever
i did president trump's physical exam
and i did his cognitive test i stood in
the press briefing room for an hour and
15 minutes and answered every single
question they could come up with
regarding his physical exam and what do
we have here we have a written report
nothing but a written report and a
useless written report at that
yeah the white house by the way
congressman did make a big announcement
today watch
there were reports that president biden
was telling allies that he is going to
run for re-election in 2024. can you
confirm is he going to run at 2024 is he
telling staff that yes that's his
intention
jim sake didn't even seem to believe
that when she said it that's his
intention so a little bit of a hedge
there
um congressman what does biden look like
in 2024 maybe they'll come out with that
cognitive test in 2023.
yeah there's no way laura there's
absolutely no way you mark my word he
will not run for president in for a
second term he'll be 82 years old then i
really i'm going to stick to what i've
been saying all along since he was
candidate biden he won't make it to the
end of this term they will remove him at
some point after the 2022 midterms
they're going to have to address these
cognitive issues it won't be ronnie
jackson talking about it anymore it's
going to be the democrats and they're
going to have to explain what's going on
with him and and make no mistake about
it there's a there's a certain number of
people in the white house right now you
know kamala harris walks past that
office every day and looks in there she
thinks i'm going to be president pretty
soon and she might be right she probably
is right and that's the only way she's
ever going to become president because
she's not going to get elected so
there's going to be a big incentive to
get him out of there
congressman um perish the thought
because kamala's even worse than the
other one congressman good to see you
tonight